[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد بعد ان اقرت
مؤخرا دول الاتحاد الاوروبي تحديدا سقفا
لسعر نفطر روسي ان فقط او انفقت اتفقت دول
مجموعه سبعه واستراليا على تحديد سعر 60
دولارا للبرميل قرار الاتحاد الاوروبي ظل
معلق نتيجه التحفظ بولندا التي ارادت سعرا
ادناه قبل ان تتراجع عن اعتراضها ما سمح
اولا باتفاق داخل تكاثر الاليه ستدخل حيث
تنفيذ الاثنين مع بدء سريان الحظر الذي
فرضه الاتحاد الاوروبي على شراء النفط
روسي عن طريق البحر لحرمه موسكو من تمويل
حربها في اوكرانيا في هذا الاطار قال
فوكين احد الخبراء في قضايا الطاقه قال ان
روسيا كسبت 7.6 مليار يورو من مبيعتها
النفسيه الى الاتحاد الاوروبي منذ بدايه
الحرب في اوكرانيا بينما تبلغ ميزاناتها
العسكريه الثانويه نحو الس مليار يورو من
جهته رحب البيض الابيض الابيض والارتفاع
معتبرا انه قد يحض من قدره بوت على
الاستفاده من سوق النفط ما يدعم اقتصاده
بلده رغم الحرب باوكرانيا ياتي هذا تزامنا
مع قرار اوبك بلس بالابقاء على العمل
بساسه انتاج النفط الحاليه والتي كانت قد
اثارت غضبا امريكيا عقب اعلانها في اكتوبر
الماضي
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من لندن راتب
سليمان العضو السابق في حزب المحافظه
البريطاني من دوله الدكتور انس الحاجه
مستشار التحرير في منصه الطاقه
الاعمال والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا بكم ضيوفي
الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من لندن معك يا
استاذ راتب ان كنت تسمع منذ قليل مقدمه
هذا الملف كانت هناك جمله معناها اتفقت
الدول الاوروبيه
العام يتحدث عن انفاق اوروبي مستمر وبانه
اوروبا تخسر في الواقع بان اوروبا تكلفه
هذه الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه همم كلفتها
الكثير فهل يمكن لهذا الاجراء الاخير ان
يساعد اوروبا ويساعد الاقتصاد العالمي همم
فعلا ام انه ضرب للاقتصاد العالمي كما هو
طبعا مساء الخير لكم وللمشاهدين الاعزاء
والضيوفكم الكرام
طبعا في هذه الحرب الاوكرانيه الجميع
الاقتصادات العالميه من روسيا الى امريكا
الى بريطانيا كل دول العالم واوروبا
تضررت من هذه الحرب اقتصاديه وخسرت الكثير
لذلك لا احد همم يربح في هذه الحرب الجميع
يخسر لان الاقتصاد العالمي الان يتدهور
شيئا فشيئا والجميع يخسر في هذه الحرب
طبعا القرار وهو تخفيض الحد ل 60 دولار
النفط طبعا سيساعد الكثير بالنسبه للدول
الاوروبيه لان الان الدول الاوروبيه عندما
تقلص سعر النفط هذا طبعا سيقلل من
الايرادات لروسيا روسيا لا تستطيع بيع
النفط
بالنسبه للدول الاوروبيه لان الدول
الاوروبيه لن تشتغل النفط من روسيا وكذلك
روسيا لا تستطيع ان ترسل الى الصين والهند
البواخر لان جميع البواخر التي تستخدمها
ستكون طبعا
تامين في بريطانيا وفي امريكا وفي اوروبا
تامين هذه السفن لذلك سيكون عليها من
الصعوبه الصعوبه كثيره جدا
الذهاب الى هذه الدول وتصدير جميعا ستخسر
تقريبا مليون ونصف برميل يوميا من انتاجها
لا تستطيع تصديره لان المسافات البعيده
بين وبين هذه الدول سيكون همم يعني صعبه
سيد درس ساعود
ساعود لك على ما هو اكثر ما زالك ولكن عن
الخسائر الروسيه اتحدث مع سيد ودار سيد
ودار هل فعلا بان هذا الاجراء بوضع السقف
لسعر النفط الروسي همم اولا يحض من قدره
روسيا الانتاجيه وثانيا كما يقول ضيفي
سيعطل امدادات روسيا همم سيعطل صادراتها
للعالم
الاجابه
همم ميزانيه الدوله الروسيه 60% منها
تتكون من الموارد الطبيعيه بالطبعه الغاز
والنفقه همها يعني 60% من الغاز والنفط
الباقي اشياء بسيطه
همم الغرب حدد روسيا اه في كثير من الامور
يعني ترى كان روسيا فقط صادرات الحبوب
بس همم
[موسيقى]
ضربه قويه من ناحيه لكن النظرنا اليوم على
اسعار النفط اليوروز حوالي 52$
عندما تشتري من الروس تشتري بتخفيض كبير
للغايه ربما يعني اقل من هذا المبلغ
المفترق الطرق يعني
عطا وهي طبعا شوفي هو الموضوع ليس اقتصادي
بحث يعني اليوم لا تاثير على الاقتصاد
الروسي لكن في المستقبل نعم تاثير كبير
همم وربما دراماتيكي همم لكن همم الكريم
يعني يقول لن نصدر لمن الذين
اتفقوا لكن سوف يصدر الكلام ده يعني اسواق
الاوروبيه هي همم اكثر ربحا بالنسبه
الروسي الصين ربما يا ملكت
وبطلت في اهانه في وجه الكلام ده من قبل
همم الغربي
يمكن ان يكون لهذه الاجراء تداعيات
دراماتيكيه هكذا وصفتها اسمح لي ان انقل
النقطه للدكتور انس دكتور انس هل هذه
التدعيات ستكون فقط دراما تكيه على روسيا
ام ان مخاوف البعض من ان ي بهذا الموضوع
على الاقتصاد العالمي وان يضر بالاقتصاد
العالمي امم فيه شيء من الصحه
علينا ان نفرق بين العقوبات او الحظر الذي
سيصبغ غدا على والدات الاتحاد الاوروبي من
روسيا وبين السقف الساري بالنسبه للسقف
الشعري لور 60 دولار هو اعلى من شعر النفط
الروسي الذي همم يتم تصديره بحرا وبالتالي
في الحقيقه لا اثر له في ارض الواقع على
الاطلاق المشكله انه اذا اصر الامريكيون
تحديدا على ان تقوم السفن ب- همم
باصدار او راء واعطائها للامريكيين او حتى
الاوروبيين ليثبت انهم اشتروه السعر
الرخيص رغم ان الجميع يعرف ان الشاعر
منخفض يعني في نوع من همم الحركه شفافه في
في اداره بوتن في هذا الموضوع لنرى ماذا
سيحصل في هذا الامر ولكن حسب ما هو
القانون حاليا لا تاثير له في ارض الواقع
على الاطلاق
يؤثر في ايرادات بوتا على الاطلاق لان
السعر اقل همم دكتور دكتور انس ما معنى
حركه ساليبوتين وضح لي اكثر ما كنت تود
الاشاره اليهم ما الذي يريده المجتمع
الدولي او على الاقل اوروبا وواشنطن من
بوتن من خلال هذا الاجراء الكل يعرف مثلا
الروسي بحدود 52 هو طبعا 52 هذا المتوسط
وبيع 48 دولار الاسبوع الماضي في وقتنا
الاوقات همم فالكل يعرف ان هذا هو الشعر
ولكن قد تسر ال- ال- الحكومه الامريكيه
على ان تثبت السفن انهم فعلا اشتروه بهذا
الشعب رغم انهم يعرفون انه بيع بهذا الشهر
على ان تقوم السفن بذلك همم اسمح لي اخي
الاستاذ راتب همم انا لا اتفق معك في
موضوع الاثر على على النفط الروسي للشباب
التالي مبيعات روسيا يعني همم الاتحاد
الاوروبي همم الشهر الماضي كانت بحدود
واحد في فصل ده مليون برميل ولكن جزء منها
كان صادرات
لتلافي ما يحصل بعد يوم الاثنين ماذا يعني
هذا ان القانون يقول انه طالما ان الشحنات
خرجت من الموانئ الروسيه قبل غدا فلا تحسب
ضمن هذا النطاق لذلك كان في شحنات كثيره
همم المفروض انها تذهب الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي لا ندري بالضبط الى اين ستذهب في
النهايه فاول شيء الكميه اقل حسب تحليلات
خبراء في مناصب الطاقه جزء منها شيء تحويل
الى دول اخرى جزء منها همم يتم همم تشريفه
في اوروبا على كل الحالات تحت مسميات
مختلفه التخفيض قد يكون فعلا بحدود 300
الى 400,000 فقط وقد تقوم الحكومه الروسيه
وشركات الروسيه
ذلك تحت فكره الصيانه
سيد راتب
همم طبعا هذا انا كمان اختلف مع الاستاذ
الكريم
ضيف يقول بانه مجرد حركه لايقاف بوتين
ولكن ليست بذاك الاجراء الكبير اللي قادر
انه يؤثر على اقتصاد روسيا
طبعا الاقتصاد الروسي منذ الحرب
الاوكرانيه يعاني الكثير كانت روسيا طبعا
في اليوم الواحد يدخلها من الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومن المانيا الغاز طبعا يدخلها
تقريبا 500 مليون دولار باليوم الواحد كان
يدخلها مبالغ كبيره ولكن الان ااه بالنسبه
لروسيا لا يدخل لها شيء من الدول
الاوروبيه المانيا لا تاخذ غاز الروسي
والدول الاوروبيه
ستعوض الغاز الروسي لذلك هذه الدول تحاول
الاستغناء عن الغاز الروسي في المستقبل
الاستغناء النهائيا ولكن في الوقت الحالي
طبعا هناك بعض الدول الاوروبيه تاخذ النفط
الروسي طبعا هو هناك بعض الدول التي اوقفت
الدول الذي التي لا تستطيع ان التي لا
تستطيع ان تؤمن نفسها من دول اخرى طبعا
بعيدا عن الغاز الروسي ضيف يقول لك فيما
يخص تحديد سقف اوروبي للنفط الروسي همم لن
تكون لا تداعيات كبيره لن يضر في القريب
الاقتصاد الروسي
ويحدثك حتى عن سفن يقول لك بانه هذا
القانون يدخل حيز التنفيذ في طاقه المعين
خرجت قبل هذا التوقيت سفن لن تطالها همم
قواعد هذا الاجراء
طبعا هذا كلام يعني هذا كلام نسمعه في
الاعلام ولكن في الحقيقه والواقع غير ذلك
الحقيقه والواقع روسيا تخسر يوميا يعني
روسيا تخسر في اقتصادها يوميا لانها لم
تصدر النفط كما كانت تصدر سابقا لما تصدر
همم الامور الاخرى كما كانت سابقا همم
روسيا الان معزوله عن الاقتصاد العالمي
الدول الاقتصاديه الكبرى لا تتعامل مع
روسيا الاقتصاد الروسيه تدهور يوما بعد
يوم روسيا الان الجميع
خلينا نسمع راي السيد ويدار في هذا الشان
تمام
انا مجرد
يعني افكر في امور ربما اوسع نطاقا
واحب الحديث بالارقام عندما نتحدث عن
مكاسب او خساره اما بنسبه او بارقام فعليه
يعني
بالاخذ في الاعتبار الاقتصاد الروسي رقم 6
في اوروبا و11 في العالم بنادق قومي 1.7
تريليون دولار
ومن المهم ان الناتج القومي
بيبر بارتي
اربعه وثلاثه من 10 التريليون دولار اي
هذه المال الذي في جيوب الروس في الحكومه
الروسيه النظرنا للضغط على اتخاذ القرار
السياسي همم لن يؤثر اي حتى لو انعدم
صادرات او الصادرات كلها من روسيا
الحكومه الروسيه ليست بريق يعني كم البعض
يعتقد سوف يتجهون للجيوب الروس
لي الاستفاده منها بين الارقام التي
ذكرتها لكن همم كما نرى الان الاثر ليس
بكثير انما هو صفى في وجه روسيا لكن
مستقبلا عندما ترتفع الاسعار
سوف يؤدي ان لم يتم تغيير قرار ااا الدول
الغنيه
قد يؤدي فعلا انهيار الاقتصاد الروسي لانه
مبني اساسا على صدره الحفريات هذه من
النفط فام اا مشكله كبيره امام الكريم
فعندما اتخذ الكريمه القرار بالذهاب الى
هذه العمليه العسكريه كان عليه يعني ههه
حتى الان اتداعيات نوعا ما همم
يعني تهويش ربما منى واسع لا لا اكثر حتى
الان لكن
العقوبه
العقبات مؤلمه انا كده مع بعض ربما لا يرى
ذلك في الارقام اليوم لان فعلا كما ذكر
الزميل اعتقد من الولايات المتحده تم
تخزين من روسيا الغاز النفط في همم على
مدار العام بعد بدايه العمريه العسكريه من
قبل الاوروبيين والامريكان حتى والغير
والصينيين الصين اوقفت مشترياتها من روسيا
المشكله نحن امام فعلا مشكله همم كبرى
كانت تؤدي لتغيير ليس فقط نظام عالمي ههه
تغيير سياسات ايضا ايضا ايضا حتى في داخل
الروسي ربما الله اعلم
مصر همم القادم في نهايه العام القادم طيب
دكتور انس ضيف يعتبر بان بعيدا عن
العقوبات كل الاجراءات الاخرى هي عمليه
تهويش لروسيا ولكن همم هل هذا يمكن ان يضر
بالاقتصاد العالمي نحن كذلك نواد ان نفكر
في هذا النظام العالمي في المصالح الدوليه
كذلك خطوه كهذا كيف يمكن ان تؤثر
نعم اشوفك عن السؤال ولكن لنتكلم لغه
الارقام اول حقيقه ان انتاج النفط الروسي
وصادرات النفط الروسي في زياده وصل لها 3
شهور في زياده مستمره والصادرات الروسيه
في زياده مستمره هذه الحقيقه الاولى
الحقيقه الثانيه ان روسيا اشترت مئات
السفن في الفتره الاخيره من حاملات النفط
لكي تتخطى كل التامين وكل اوروبا بالكامل
ما ينقص روسيا الان حتى تغطي كل صادراته
هو بحدود 150 سفينه بين امريكا اللاتينيه
وافريقيا والشرق الاوسط والهند والصين
تستطيع التغطيه ال 150 سفينه بدون تامين
من اوروبي على كل الحالات قامت الحكومه
الصينيه وقامت الحكومه الهنديه وقامت
الحكومه الروسيه
بتوفير تامين لهذه السفن المضائق المائيه
لان هذا متطلب من الدول التي تشرف على
المضايق همم المائيه بشكل عام لو نظرنا من
جانب الاخر اخر متوسط الشعر الذي تحصل
عليه روسيا الان يماثل متوسط الشعر في
العام الماضي والعامل الماضي كانت روسيا
ما عندها مشكله نهائيا التضخم في روسيا
الان اقل من اوروبا بشكل كبير انا اخر شيء
اريد ان ادافع عن روسيا وبوتا على فكره
انا لا ادافع عنهم ولكن هذه هي لغه لغه
الارقام
ولو انه ليس موضوع ان نحن موضوعنا تحديد
سقف في اسعار النفط ولكن عن التضخم في
روسيا عن الحاله الاقتصاديه في روسيا ضيف
يقول سيد ودار بانه وكان بوتين اما نفسها
في مرحله من المراحل قبل ان يتدهور الوضع
اه اوك نتحدث بالارقام مثل ما يعني متعود
مع
عملائي
التضخم حسب توقعاتي الشخصيه ضعيف من
الرسمي سوف يصل الى 20% تضخم السعر
لو قرينا باوروبا هذه هي ال ال الماساه في
روسيا هناك ماساه في التضخم نعم لا
مظاهرات
في اوروبا ناقصه
ناتج القومي المتوقع من الحكومه الروسيه
في حدود 3% انا اعتقد سوف يكون ربما اكثر
من اربعه في المئه
من من ما نشاهده الان اا العمله الروسيه
همم ارتي فيشل موازنه للدولار واليورو
يعني
لا توجد لا يوجد تداول نعم هناك بورصه نعم
هناك قائد كبير للغايه من العمله الصعبه
في روسيا لكن لا شيء ممكن ش اهو ينفع روسي
لان اهو عقوبه
فالانتاج في روسيا يتقلص لا يزيد
فالامور ليست
با ربما البراكه للفريق الذي
يشاهد هذا الملعب للكره
من العرب
قليلا بان ضيفه من موسكو سيد ودار يتحدث
عن ماساه في روسيا همم وانت متعود على
الدفاع على وجهه النظر روسيه ولكنك
جميل جميل ان يكون الانسان ينقل هذا
الواقع وظيفه من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يقول بان بوتين امانا نفسه وحضر
لكل هذا طيب هذا يمكن همم
اعتقد ان المقارنه غير صحيح في هذه
الطريقه لان المقارنه يجب ان تتم بينما
كان متوقعا في بدايه الحرب وما يحصل الان
كان متوقع ان تكون الامور اسوا بكثير من
الوضع الحقيقي واسوء بكثير مما يقوله همم
صديقنا من روسيا همم فحتى كلامه هو افضل
بكثير من ما كان متوقعا في الفتره الاولى
بالنسبه للاقتصاد العالمي للدكتور حجي قبل
ان انتقل الى لندن باختصار لو سمحت
الاقتصاد العالمي في خطر كبير نتيجه عده
تصرفات ااه قامت بها همم وتشرفات غير
مدروسه همم بشكل صحيح
من ناحيه العقوبات خاصه بما يتعلق
بالاغذيه وشحن الاغذيه وكما قال ضيفك
الموضوع همم الاسمده لان هذا شيء يؤثر على
الموسم الجراعي القادم همم في كل انحاء
العالم حسن في همم في دول العالم الثالث
او الدول الناميه وهناك مشكله كبيره قادمه
التضخم لان ينتهي بهذه الشهوله والمشاكل
التي تنتهي بهذه السهوله حتى لو توقفت
الحلقه
باختصار نعم ام لا نعم همم سيد راتب هل
يجر الاتحاد الاوروبي العالم الى ركود حاد
يصف بعض
نعم سيكون هناك ركود وليس ركود حادث يكون
هناك ركود اقتصادي الى ان نرى الحرب نهايه
للحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه السبب الركود
وسبب المشاكل وسببه هبوط او صعود الاسعار
هو بسبب الحرب الاوكرانيه لذلك نرى نعم
سنرى
اجراءات الاوروبيه اجراءات الاتحاد
الاوروبي لم تدخن كذلك من هذه الصعوبات
التي يعيشها العالم ضيف يقول بان هكذا
اجراء قادر كذلك ان يصعب الامور ان يحملنا
من تضخم الى ركود
نعم هذا سيعاني منه جميع دول العالم بما
فيها حتى اوروبا نعم هنا المواطن الاوروبي
كذلك سيعاني كما يعاني المواطن
الروسياتها وكانها تقول عليا وعلى اعدائي
الكل يعني تتخذ اجراء وسيتحمله العالم على
كلن سيبقى موضوع للمتابعه شكرا لكم
قد المتابع هذا نقاش ولكن لاحقا شكرا
جزيلا لك من لندن راتب سليمان العضو
السابق في حزب المحافظه البريطاني من دلع
دكتور انس الحاج مستشار وتحرير في منصه
الطاقه
الاعمال والعلاقات الدوليه شكرا لكم